There's a kind of suffering that doesn't just linger, it expands.
It doesn't fade with time, it grows,
and nowhere is this more evident than in the quiet, suffocating beauty of the unfinished.
Take Michelangelo's slaves, those marble figures half-emerged from the stone,
straining against their own creation.
Were they ever meant to be free?
Or were they always meant to be this, a testament to the artist's refusal to let go?
For the rest of us, the unfinished isn't a flaw, it's a philosophy.
We call it the archive of incomplete projects.
Most people chase closure.
They want the neat bow, the final period, the satisfaction of a job well done.
The maven, however, seeks something far more exquisite.
Perpetual opening. Start fifty things. Finish none.
Let your mind become a city of half-built towers,
a symphony of four bars that will never resolve.
This isn't indecision. This is design.
The brain, as we learned in the ghosting protocol,
is a machine built for the unresolved.
It remembers the half-sent text, the half-painted wall,
the half-written novel gathering dust,
like a relic of a life that might have been.
Keep fifty open loops spinning somewhere.
A guitar collects dust.
A business plan from 2021 still haunts your desktop.
A novel begins with a single, bold sentence, and then, silence.
You become a human hub, a nexus of your own failures,
a walking ledger of what could have been.
And here's how you cultivate it.
First, the high.
That moment when a new project is born by the domain,
the tools, the social media handles.
Let the dopamine rush in, thick and intoxicating.
This is your peak, your peak and rule in action.
The memory of this moment will outlast the reality of what comes next.
And what comes next, of course, is friction.
As soon as the work demands something real your time,
your effort, your attention pivot,
abandon it, move to the next shiny thing.
This isn't laziness.
This is strategy.
Every pivot expands your resume of regrets,
a growing monument to the lives you might have lived
if only you'd finished something.
If you find yourself dangerously close to completion,
ghost it.
Don't delete the files.
Toss them into a folder labeled to do or urgent.
Let it fester.
This is your cemetery of the self,
a graveyard of potential where every tombstone
bears the name of a dream you let die.
And when someone asks what you're working on
at the next dinner party of discomfort,
you'll smile and say,
oh, just a few things.
Four ventures, actually.
They'll nod, impressed by your ambition.
They won't see the truth.
You're not a multi-potentialite.
You're a human draft.
A work in progress with no architect in sight.
The goal isn't productivity.
It's perpetual construction.
You are a half-painted wall,
a room where the other half will never be finished.
Every glance is a slight from your past self,
a reminder of what you left undone.
And yet, you stay alive.
You stay unfinished.
Completion is the death of potential.
Stay alive.
Stay unfinished.
That's the archive.